notre invité politique ce matin série
coquerel bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous députés la france en
soliste de seine-saint-denis en étant
son pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenter ce
matin par stéphane bern est bonjour
stéphane bonjour gardant stéphane qui
dirige le bureau parisien du journal
ouest france
on commence bien évidemment eric
coquerel par la crise sanitaire et le
vaccinodromes au stade de france qui est
donc lancée ce matin dans votre
département ce sera le plus grand et
cynodrome de france est ce que c'est un
soulagement pour le département de la
seine saint denis
ça peut l'être à une condition c'est que
ça soit pas au détriment des centres de
proximité même qu'on renforce les
centres de proximité pour une bonne
raison c'est que chacun comprendra que
c'est parfois compliqué notamment pour
les personnes âgées justement qui en
seine saint denis en plus souffrent
beaucoup de la fracture numérique
c'est pour ça qu'on a critiqué le fait
qu'on passe par des plateformes type dr
libre et non pas directement
c'est difficile pour des personnes âgées
d'aller jusqu'à justement un stade qui
parfois loin d'eux donc il faut
renforcer les centres de proximité ou
jouer à mon ami has been taibi kemer de
stains parents qui en réclament il a
bien raison
alors si c'est pour finir là-dessus
s'est voulu rassurant il ya 13 heures de
tf1 il a dit ça sera pas concurrence à
sera complémentaire ça ne se fera pas au
détriment de ses centres de vaccination
en général quand je suivais range me
méfie parce que des fois une semaine
après il dit des choses différentes mais
je verrai mais par contre une deuxième
chose à mon avis absolument nécessaire
c'est que ça permette aussi de changer
de stratégie de vaccination
jusqu'à maintenant la stratégie de
vaccination c'est et de prioriser et je
peux le comprendre évidemment les
personnes les plus à risque donc les
personnes les plus âgées mais il ya un
critère qu'on n'a pas du tout pris en
compte qui est la dangerosité de se
contaminer ca les personnes qui sont les
plus susceptibles de se contaminer par
exemple les enseignants par exemple les
gens qui sont ce qu'on appelle emprunt
en ligne et en seine saint denis ils
sont nombreux et de ce fait la
répartition des vaccins par département
s'est fait au détriment de département
populaire comme la seine-saint-denis on
est à peu près à moitié moins de doses
de vaccins que la moyenne nationale pour
cette raison de route nous commandons
jeu notamment fait une lettre avec mon
collègue stéphane peu qui est également
maire de députés de ça ni pardon ce que
nous demandons c'est que avec ce
vaccinodromes on change la stratégie et
que
vienne prioritaires et bien tous les
publics les plus les plus fragiles jeu
parce que parce qu'ils prennent le plus
de risques de contaminer c'est drôlement
également le président du département de
la seine saint denis la part du maintien
autant vous êtes d'accord avec vous est
sur la même ligne en tout cas l'enjeu
l'enjeu en gène d'une manière générale
c'est que les populations de seine saint
denis est un département
particulièrement touché soit
effectivement prioritaire et que
l'ouverture du stade de france
permettent de diffuser massivement la
vaccination
oui dans ce département dans ce
territoire c'est en abordant ce
département il faut je parle de ce
département non seulement parce que j'en
suis élu non seulement parce que vous
savez que le vaccin en renforcent les
inégalités c'est déjà et maintenant il
ya beaucoup d'inégalités entre entzheim
fuite mais c'est aussi pour contrer la
maladie
parce que si des personnes qui vont
travailler prennent le métro tous les
jours vont dans des dandys en grance
contamine vont à l'école se contaminent
il en contamine d'autres donc sur ces
demandes que vous n'êtes formulé qui
paraissent de bon sens est ce que vous
êtes entendu maintenant pour l'instant
on n'est pas entendu et d'ailleurs donc
vous allez allez aucune assurance à
l'intérêt de revenir un petit peu
globalement sur ce qui se passe c'est
que ce qui vient d'être annoncé marque
l'échec du gouvernement en janvier
en janvier ce qui a été annoncé alors
qu'on savait que le variant où il est
arrivé on avait quasiment tous les
chiffres c'était s'était pas de
l'objectif de fermer les écoles et de re
confiner le pays de manière encore plus
drastiques en avril l'objectif c'était
de tenir voire là on arrive à quelle
situation c'est que monsieur véran
annonce que à la fin du mois on aura
atteint les capacités la capacité totale
de lits de réanimation
donc on sait pas très bien quand on
atteint la capacité on sait pas très
bien si on reste pas au dessus et moi
j'ai vu notamment il ya très peu de
jours à l'hôpital bichat quitte à la
pointe de le convainc contrôle qu'ovide
des professeurs qui sont très inquiets
de ce point de vue là et on y à 40000
contamination jours donc le pari ce
sanitaires et le pari économique du
gouvernement qui était de ne pas
déplacer le plafond des 20000 qui
permettait de continuer l'économie et
pour continuer l'économie il faut que
vos écoles restent ouvertes les parents
puissent travailler c'est un échec total
donc maintenant ce dont il s'agit j'en
viens au sujet c'est que au moins on
réussisse ce nouveau déconfinement
prince un gouvernement a tout faux donc
moi ce que je demande c'est très
pratique il aimerait bien que monsieur
verrons quand on le demande
france a soumis avec jean luc mélenchon
nous répondent c'est qu'on demande par
exemple que ce mois ci soit consacrée au
fait qu' on prépare une rentrée
réellement dédoublant les classes moi je
ne crois pas la situation en cours au
mois de mai tout va être père veilleux
la situation va être va être éclaircis
xterra donc il faudrait qu'on dit d'où
les classes qu'on n'a pas fait il
faudrait pour la deuxième chose c'est
que vous permet d'isoler davantage les
malades pour moi c'est mon dada c'est à
dire que j'ai vu que l' oms avait avait
de ce point de vue la danse et l'union
européenne sur sur cette capacité faut
comprendre que quand vous êtes malade et
même simplement contaminées en
seine-saint-denis ailleurs on ne vous
propose pas l'hébergement pour vous
protéger donc vous contaminer des gens
en plus dans des appartements qui sont
souvent plus étroit donc ça c'est une
deuxième priorité créer des lits on en
n'a pas créé en un an j'ai pas si vous
rendez compte on est toujours au même
nom de lits potentiels qui a un an et
puis la licence publique du vaccin qui
me semble plus mon priori on va revenir
sur les vaccins mais juste pour finir
sur les mesures qui ont été prises
notamment pour la seine saint denis un
qui est l'un des départements les plus
touchés de france en taux d'incidence
est ce que vous dites ces mesures à
l'heure actuelle à l'heure où l'on se
parle sont les bonnes dans l'immédiat
mais elles sont pas les bonnes pour des
cons préparer à des profits ne le dit
mais dans l'immédiat pour faire baisser
le taux d'incidence dans votre des biens
on sait très bien le taux d'incidence va
continuer à monter de jusqu'à fin avril
le monsieur verront la lumière non dans
département et ailleurs il va continuer
à monter
ce serait le cas parce que la fermeture
des écoles étaient devenus sinon les
sinon ce qui se passait si on fermait
pas les écoles c'est qu'on n'arrivait
pas à saturation la fin du mois d'avril
ont débordé par tour les hôpitaux avec
les conséquences je tiens dans
l'immédiat c'est ce qu'il fallait faire
oui dans l'immédiat c'est ce qu'il
fallait faire mais rouler obligé de le
faire parce que ce gouvernement n'a pas
anticipé depuis le premier déconfinement
la situation à venir voilà mais vous
êtes en train de nous promettre l'échec
des mesures en vigueur et l'impossible
ils n'ont donc je suis en train de me
dire et consulter à nouveau en mai je
suis en train de vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui gouvernement compte sur
une chose le vaccin d'accord je remarque
d'ailleurs qu'il adore le reste c'est ça
sur le rail ce club pour le reste il
nous propose aucune autre alternative
et moi je pense que c'est vraiment un
service est pas une liberté parents
d'être en cours
peut partir 19h de faire du métro boulot
dodo et on va pas pouvoir rester une
société en confinement pendant des mois
et des mois et moi je pense que c'est
juste par contre de ce point de vue là
que ça va durer ça va durer au delà du
mois d'avril
en tout cas j'attends de voir j'aimerais
bien que le vaccin soit le succès
annoncé
mais vous savez comme moi par exemple
quand vous vacciner vous savez
aujourd'hui qu'on ne peut pas vous
garantir le fait de ne plus contaminés
personne c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
peut vous garantir et il faut donc je
commence à faire et level 5 est la
solution encore faudrait-il que on ouvre
à d'autres vaccins je pense aux vaccins
risquons que la france soit enfin
favorable à la l'ouverture en licence
publique du vaccin ce parce
qu'aujourd'hui à les contrats l'a voté
contre au niveau de l'om c'est en
octobre 2020 sakho savoir monsieur macro
avait promis qu'il était pour cette
option ils ont voté contre la
proposition de l'afrique du sud et
l'inde
et puis deuxième chose à côté qu'on
mette des mesures alternatives au
confinement mais je le pose sur les
vaccins puisque vous parlez des licences
la france ça va se lancer dans la
production de ces vaccins entrait dans
la mise en bouteille de certains vaccins
bruno le maire dit que le rates de 150
millions de doses d'ici la fin de
l'année qui seront produites en france
où beaucoup de choses merveilleuses mais
est ce que est ce que durent les sens
public qu'est ce que ça changerait si on
est déjà justement c'est le terme que
vous avez utilisé vous avez rectifier
c'est très bien la france ne va pas
produire à partir de mercredi des
millions de doses de vaccins elle va
embouteillée des vaccins qui ont été
dans les composantes ont été fabriqués
en allemagne c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose que l'autonomie tous
réclament aux d'accord alors j'ai vu
j'ai vu une phrase extraordinaire je
peux pas même la cité de de madame agnès
pannier rue n'a fait qui a dit la crise
due qu'au guide a révélé à quel point 30
ans 18 inscrits des nains de free bien
désindustrialisation du secteur de la
pharmacie ont réduit l'outil
l'outil disponible bravo mais le
problème c'est qu'on continue à faire
pareil nous ça fait des années qu'on
demande justement une autre politique
pour les laboratoires d'arrêter de
donner de l'argent sans contrepartie à
sanofi qui a reçu 1,25 milliard d'euros
d'argent public en disant tout en
supprimant des milliers d'emplois très
centres de recherche en france plus
tentant de 140% de bénéfices
ça fait longtemps par exemple qu'on
demande aux gouvernements malin panir
une hache et lui demandai-je tort que
par exemple des entreprises à bobigny
comme peter chirurgicale figurez-vous
c'est une entreprise qui fabrique des
petites secondes absolument
indispensable pour les lits de
réanimation elle en a fabriqué quatre
fois plus pendant la première vague que
d'habitude et vous savez ce qui est
arrivé depuis cette entreprise qui était
bénéficiaire a fermé d'accord les
salariés ont été licenciés pour que
l'entreprise faisait ce serait ouvrir
ailleurs en inde donc ce gouvernement
pour le coup sur la question de la la
souveraineté sanitaires sur la question
de la souveraineté du vaccin pour
l'instant n'a rien fait au contraire il
a aggravé les problèmes si on veut
demain produire enfin à vaccins en
france et c'est quand même incroyable
que la patrie pasteur n'ai pas été
capable de le faire
il faut effectivement changer de fond en
comble notre stratégie en terme de
recherche
un dernier mot dernière 500 vaccins on a
vu dans certains centres de vaccination
les doses d'astrazeneca ne trouvait pas
preneur faute de volontaires parce qu'il
ya doute suspicion sur le ne quittais du
vaccin est ce que c'est le cas également
en seine saint denis et c'est le cas
partout c'est le cas partout et vous
quelle est votre position est ce que
vous inciter quand même les gens à vous
vacciner en disant il va ma position
c'est qu'on a intérêt vital à ouvrir à
d'autres vaccins pour que les gens aient
le choix parce que astrazeneca
les gens sont pas responsable si un jour
on a expliqué qu'il fallait vacciner les
moins de 55 ans et puis après celle
inverse et que on nous révèle quand même
des cas au moins de vous savez très bien
que le personnel soignant hésitent à se
faire vacciner
c'est ça la réalité l'a laissé ma
réalité en même pas le cas les agents
parlent ils sont ultra minoritaires par
rapport au nombre de jeux est faible les
gens vaccinés je ne suis pas le
contraignant à l'ailé les effets induits
mineurs sont pas minoritaire mais
qu'importe justement il ya eu 1 ce qu'on
regarde c'est que c'est vrai que ça a
vraiment eu des phases accéléré de tests
beau
voilà ça allait trop vite c'est bien
pour ça que je pense qu'il faut très
rapidement diversifier l'origine sans
préjugés idéologiques géostratégique
éclairage parle notamment du vaccin
risque mais pas que et un sens que les
gens et les choix je pense qu on
améliorerait les choses c'est des
préjugés idéologiques ou c'est le fait
qu'il ya pas d'autorisation non c'est
que rennes non oui mais d'accord mais
les autorisations européennes c'est une
décision politique
c'est le fait qu'on est soumis aux
règles du marché grec de l'union
européenne voit là et qu'on a la france
de ce point de vue là perdu son
autonomie
jeffrey martin america était beaucoup
plus offensive tout de suite vis-à-vis
du vaccin russes par exemple en termes
d'ouverture que que nous l'avons fait
voilà nous on est très obéissant aux
marchés je pense que dans une situation
comme ça c'est pas le marché de
capacités de production sur ce vaccin
russe qui freinent je pense j'en sais
rien vous trouvez que les capacités de
production aujourd'hui on a des raisons
mais avec le problématique du vaccin
russe du scout knicks et peu en russie
elle même il est très peu utilisé et
c'est peut-être probablement qu'un
problème a produit il ya le chinois est
encore une fois je le répète surtout il
ya le fait que hoarau revienne à cette
licence publique
macron l'avait annoncé l'avait promis et
la france y contre on va parler c'est
tout aussi important de la crise
économique de la crise sociale la crise
économique notamment puisque bruno le
maire ce n'est qu'à la revue les
chiffres de la croissance à la baisse
les chiffres du déficit et de la dette à
la hausse la dette qui frôle désormais
les 120% du pib va se poser la question
du remboursement de sa dette
comment on fait les coquerelles comment
on fait déjà oui j'ai vu l'interview de
monsieur le maire ça serait pas très
sympa au avec les vrp si je le compare
enfin il est quand même très bonimenteur
lorsque la situation économique en
france
faut vraiment mettre des lunettes roses
pour les lavoirs positive aujourd'hui on
a une situation qui est en termes de
perte de pib par rapport à il ya un an
absolument catastrophique et le les
richesses qui sont perdus on va
continuer a pas pendant deux ans
malheureusement des répercussions voilà
moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est que et je
crois que c'est la raison pour
lesquelles monsieur le maire présente
aussi positivement les résultats c'est
que ce gouvernement à refermer
complètement la page le chapitre
légèrement ouvert par monsieur macro il
ya un an d'un d'un autre monde
voilà il fallait créer il fallait
réfléchir notre monde est par exemple
pour réfléchissent à la question des
îles
qualité pourquoi pas disait-il même sur
la stratégie sanitaire qu'on nationalise
à l'époque des gens comme monsieur le
maire des gens comme monsieur woerth le
président de la commission des finances
quand on leur disait que finalement la
dette était un poids ce qu'on agite et
souvent pour contraindre les peuples à
des politiques de de baisse des dépenses
publiques des politiques de réformes
structurelles me disais mais chacun sait
que la dette on la rembourse jamais cas
les perpétuelles eux-mêmes l'admettait
un an après le discours a changé
donc ça veut dire qu'en fait ils veulent
redémarrer l'économie exactement sur les
mêmes bases néo libérales que celles qui
ont mis le pays dans la situation nous
sommes aujourd'hui voilà je crois que
c'est ça dont il s'agit est pour vous
dire sur la dette qui a une solution
pour la dette
aujourd'hui il avait dit qu vide
inquiets d'aujourd'hui par la banque de
france puisque la banque de france aisne
délégation l'avant-centre local c'est de
la nuit aujourd'hui ces dettes n'est pas
n'est pas détenu par les marchés elle
n'est pas soumise aux contraintes du
marché c'est nous qui la détenons via
notre banque centrale donc vous pouvez
très bien décider ça a été fait dans
d'autres grandes périodes historiques
que vu les circonstances exceptionnelles
vous annulé cette dette et vous n'en
faites pas porter le poids justement sur
sur le pays avec ce chantage permanent
qu'on fait à la dette donc en chargeant
le faire mais on l'a déjà fait on vient
les liban la banque centrale européenne
vient de l même de racheter du show
montes qui interrompt les traités ne
permettent pas donc de toutes façons les
traités ont déjà été j'allais dire
dépassé va passer l'actualité 3 3 nuits
d'échauffourées à creil la semaine la
semaine dernière avec des policiers
attaqués à coups de cocktails molotov et
de mortiers de mortiers d'artifices vous
avez gérald darmanin et jean castex qui
sort du commissariat donc dans l'oise à
creil hier pour manifester leur soutien
indéfectible quel est le regard que vous
portez sur sur ce type de situation et
sur la situation générale du pays
havas la situation générale du pays elle
est très mauvaise et l'effet que cette
tension là elle ils ont elles sont elles
sont significatives de de ce qui est en
train de nous arriver où jack surtout
ces tensions le fait qu'elle se répète
comme ça il
outre le fait que c'est très dur pour un
pays d'être mis en confinement au
couvre-feu et c'est encore plus dur
qu'on vivait dans des situations pour
vous c'est un rapport directement avec
et il n'y a pas de poids je vous fais
une confidence je parle ce n'est pas lié
aux histoires de travail très inquiète
il peut y avoir en plus des situations
mais qui scellera filles ça c'est clair
c'est la raison pour lesquelles je suis
en train d'initier une proposition de
loi à l'assemblée nationale contre le
trafic de drogue qui est un fléau qui
est le fluo principe principal on va
dire aujourd'hui notamment des quartiers
populaires pour les populations qui
subissent pour les petites mains de la
drogue pour les consommateurs mais
au-delà de ça je pense qu'il ya une
situation aujourd'hui où déjà la vie
était vraiment pas simple du fait des
inégalités du fait du manque de services
publics du fait de la déscolarisation
etc etc mais là c'est clair que la crise
ne fait qu'accentuer ça et que ça met
une pression terrible
on pourrait avoir d'autres craignent
j'espère que non mais oui c'est possible
c'est possible de la situation
savez vous pouvez pas sans arrêt
demander à des gens j'allais dire de
vive ans métro boulot dodo et puis et
puis point barre pendant des mois sans
que c'est des répercussions
psychologiques sociales et tous ne le
sait tout le monde le dit donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faut vite trouver des
alternatives à la situation que vivent
aujourd'hui on va parler de l'actualité
à l'assemblée nationale marquée
notamment cette semaine par ce texte sur
la fin de vie qui sera examinée jeudi
par les députés 3000 âmes on monte
étaient déposés dont une immense
majorité par des députés à l'ère du coup
l'examen du texte qui risque de ne pas
pouvoir se faire dans le temps imparti
qu'est ce que vous dites vous dites
c'est de l'obstruction parlementaire
qu'on dénonce où vous dites mais à ses
députés ils sont dans leur rôle
non non enfin ils sont dans leur rôle de
le faire mais je dis elle fera entendre
raison quoi il ya un débat on a été plus
de 250 je crois signé députés de toutes
les deux tous les formations politiques
y compris des républicains que monsieur
reda a signé une pétition demandant au
moins qu'ils aient pas d'obstruction
qu'on puisse aller au bout de ce débat
voilà moi je crois que nous nous sommes
pour cette profession de loi qui permet
j'allais dire à l'être humain de deux
d'avoir un libre arbitre
y compris justement sur sa fin de vie
voilà c'est ça le droit à l'euthanasie
pour aller vite et on voit bien que
c'est quelque chose qui évolue dans la
société de manière considérable et il
serait quand même dommage que quelques
une poignée de députés en déposant
chacun 400 un moment c'est ça dont il
s'agit
block en réalité cette fois est ce que
pour tout le monde comprenne une
proposition de loi venant d'un groupe si
elle n'est pas votée et adoptée avant
une heure fatidique
el al est annulé il sait ce que c'est ce
qui est recherché ne s'est pas de
manière de droit de demander de retirer
ses amis bien sûr bien sûr ce qui
peut-être qu'il faudra dire aussi c'est
que c'est une poignée de députés
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils le font parce que
probablement ceux de ce type de sujet
aujourd'hui mieux entre guillemets pour
passer dans la société y compris au
parlement donc y compris au sénat oui
oui bien y avoir une majorité sur cour
j'espère d'ailleurs et donc on est on
est face à un petit groupe qui décide
finalement de deux décident de bloquer
prônant l'usagé des commentaires là on
va parler des questions politiques pour
terminer et yannick jadot qui propose
donc à l'ensemble de la gauche une
réunion dans les quinze jours la france
est soumise ira cette réunion vous
l'avais déjà dit vous irez avec quel
message
nous on veut bien parler toujours parler
de programme nous pose le maître aucun
problème là on a écrit moi qui m'en
occupe en l'occurrence pour pour prendre
la campagne présidentielle de jean luc
mélenchon on a écrit à tous les partis a
maintenant des semaines pour les
rencontrer pour confronter programme
contre fera vous avez fait vous avez vu
aussi qu'on a fait à comparateur de
programmes
donc ça nous pose aucun problème je
parle des partis de gauche donc si
monsieur jadot arrive à faire une
réunion à ce que encore faut-il qu'elles
aient lieu j'ai remarqué quand même que
il ya certains s'interrogent notamment
dans son corps lui disant au nom de quoi
il prend cette initiative puisque pour
l'instant il n'est qu'un candidat une
primaire du camp écologiste boursiers
monsieur jadot arrive à monter cette
réunion dès qu'on veut le fait qu'elle
soit je vous donne chaude oui j'attends
de voir et la deuxième chose c'est que
ça ne peut pas être plié à quelque chose
qui nous qui qui signifierait à l'avant
ce qu'on va être capables de s'entendre
sur un dénominateur commun minimal entre
des formations qui ont aujourd'hui des
des clivages importants sur la question
économique malheureusement peut-être
aussi sur les questions éthiques
et voilà donc moi si on me rappelle
alors je vais vous expliquer lequel on a
fait face aux attaques du gouvernement
face aux attaques de l'extrême droite
face à ces attaques malheureusement
compris une partie de la droite sur les
questions globales vidal organise une
chasse aux sorcières sur l'université au
nom de l'islamo gauchisme sur la
question de monsieur blanc caire parlant
de point de faciste vis-à-vis d'eux
syndicat unef qui autorise des groupes
de parole en son sein et qui appartenait
ne réagit même pas quand il ya une
demande de dissolution de ce type de
syndicat ce qui serait quand même
instrument incroyable dans une
démocratie il ya beaucoup de choses qui
se passe je parle même pas des lois
liberticides sécurité globale et nous on
veut que la gauche on est capable de
réagir ensemble on a proposé une réunion
en mars à tout le monde
le parti communiste le parti socialiste
n'était pas venu au rhdp que je n'aime
pas voulu signer la déclaration nous
remettons le couvert
nour proposons une réunion ce 7 avril
c'est à dire mercredi avec deux
organisations en génération le npa on a
fait appel à tout le monde et si on
n'est pas capable déjà de réagir jaillir
dans l'action sur le minimal c'est à
dire sur la défense des libertés
publiques sur notre position
discrimination lois discriminantes
liberticide très franchement j'ai un peu
du mal après à penser après qu'on peut
parler programme mais je savais qu'on
soit bien clair le préalable c'est quoi
cette c'est que les partis logique
puisque c'est demain vers vienne à votre
énoncé pas notre union c'est plus un
parti qu'on fait c'est une proposition
on est une dizaine à une déclaration
commune c'est ça au moins déjà pour
commencer et puis peut-être même les
actions est prévu nous parents plus
grande initiative pour les libertés avec
les associations les syndicats qu'au
printemps au projet et réfléchir à ça il
faut réagir parce que le climat de ce
point de vue la réaction demain vous ne
lirez pas à la réunion
j'adore en tout cas on va y aller ce
thème papa j'espère que mercredi on
serait capable de se réunir et da de
dire des choses ensemble là dessus vous
parlez de clivage important ce que ce
sont des clivages rédhibitoire
aujourd'hui ce que vous faites le
constat que de toute façon c'est foutu y
aura pas d'alliance à gauche points au
premier tour très franchement je pense
qu'il y aura donc chacun ayant un
ordinateur une candidature
d'accommodement est que ce système là
pour aller vite la suite de hollande
avec peut-être avec quelques variantes
mais qui qui ne remet pas en question
fondamentalement par le discours sur la
dette
le discours sur l'union européenne les
sur les traités européens et serra et
puis une candidature si jusqu'à depuis
2017 et quand même majoritaire à gauche
c'est à dire celle de la rupture avec
jean luc mélenchon
je pense qu'on arrivera à ça par contre
qu'il n'ait pas joué c'est un coup dur
pour la gauche au deuxième tour elle a
repensé le parti sis sur la grande force
ça s'est pas jouée par exemple donc ces
dernières
nous jouons second roman où il est
encore possible que jean luc mélenchon
soit au second tour même si on part pour
gouverner le pays
toutes les mesures je vous ai annoncé
tout à l'heure d'alternative au profil
mans on espère bien un jour les mettre
en application enfin j'espère pas par
rapport aux qu'ovide on aura passé la
chaume et on espère montrer que notre
efficacité pour gouverner le pays dans
une dans le sens d'une politique à la
fois écologiques de la sixième
république du partage des richesses
parce que c'est et c'est à mon avis la
seule solution pour gagner cette
élection
et c'est la seule solution pour sortir
le pays de l'ornière et merci beaucoup
merci avec israël d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin merci stéphane on
regarde la une d'ouest france consacrée
aux 25
comment la france s'inscrit dans
l'effort européen c'est à la une de
ouest france ce matin merci beaucoup
[Musique]